on a fait depuis 40 ans des gains de
productivité colossaux depuis 1975 en
gros la ksa l'ordinariat une double
révolution des ordinateurs partout voilà
sept merci beaucoup à la régie cette
coupe est vraiment très impressionnante
vous l'avez dire en début de votre
exposé que la question du temps de
travail est un mouvement historique et
on a divisé par trois le temps de
travail entre 1820 et 1970 le on a
interdit le travail des enfants on est
passé de 7 jours à 6 2 6 jours à 5 voilà
mais on a mis des congés payés on a fait
des journées de 10 heures et 18 heures
donc en gros alors qu'il n'y avait pas
tellement de gains de productivité on a
divisé par trois le temps de travail
dans ta et depuis entre 1820 et 1970 et
voyez énorme depuis 1916 dustrit yale
oui mais pas dans wii wii mais pendant
oui mais c'est jusqu'à l'échelle ce
qu'on vit depuis 40 ans avec une double
révolution les ordinateurs et les
machines et puis là le sait qu'en france
on a multiplié par sept le nombre
d'étudiants qui vont faire des études à
l'université après le bac cette double
révolution c'est qu'on a fait des gains
de productivité de géant depuis 1975
de 8,75 le temps de travail pour un
salarié à temps plein a quasiment pas
baissé j'ai regardé hier pour préparer
l'émission les chiffres de l'insee
aujourd'hui en france un homme ou une
femme qui est à temps plein et à 39
1h39 une heure si la durée réelle
aujourd'hui pour un temps plein en
france c'est quasiment la même chose
qu'en 1975 dont le niveau n'est pas la
guerre belga la mère est aujourd'hui de
nous dire qu'il faut aussi
le niveau de vie n'a pas augmenté leurs
enfants rien du tout je dis qu'on est
juste beaucoup beaucoup plus riche mais
qu'il ya cinq millions de chômeurs sans
compter ceux qui trouvent plus compté au
chômage passent ils sont au rsa
[Musique]